Voiceover: I'm here
with Elizabeth Slavitt.
What do you do here at the Khan Academy?
Elizabeth: Well I work on the
school implementations team,
which means that I work with schools
that want to use Khan Academy software,
to individualize in their classrooms
and to be really innovative.
I work with them to figure
out how to make that happen.
I also work on lots of different
parts of the product and things too.
Since we're a startup we
all kind of do everything.
Voiceover: And what were
you doing before this?
What's kind of the arc of your career?
What did you think you were going
to do when you were in college,
and what did you end up doing, and then
how did you essentially end up here?
Elizabeth: Sure, yeah.
Those are great questions.
So, in college I studied history at Penn.
I studied, actually, intellectual
history, so the history of ideas.
I focused a lot on human rights.
I really was interested and still
am interested in human rights,
and how that term changes
in meaning over time.
I thought about spending my career
in human rights in some way,
which is very vague and
kind of very esoteric idea.
Voiceover: Idealistic.
Sounds good though.
Elizabeth: Idealistic, yes.
Also kind of vague.
After college I wanted
some tangible skills,
so I went and worked as a
management consultant at McKinsey,
where I got to help solve a lot
of really interesting problems.
Voiceover: So to work at
McKinsey coming out of U,
you must have been a pretty good student.
Elizabeth: Yeah, I was a good student.
Voiceover: Like McKinsey, if
you have straight C students
they don't interview, right?
Elizabeth: Yeah, I guess not (laughs).
Voiceover: Well anyway.
What was your thought [unintelligible],
because went from a very idealistic
human rights, save the world,
to oh I'm going to go whisper in CEOs ears
and tell them how to run their company.
What was the-
Elizabeth: Yeah, there's
a lot of whispering.
Voiceover: Yeah, exactly [unintelligible].
So what was the thought, McKinsey's
a great company obviously.
What was the thought process
of deciding to do that?
Elizabeth: Yeah.
I guess I felt like coming out of college,
there was actually an interesting article
recently about this in the Atlantic,
about how a lot of people go and
study these really esoteric things,
and then they're like, "I don't have any
skills. Let me go become a consultant,
"or work on Wall Street or
something and learn some skills."
That was kind of true for me.
I knew I wanted to solve
complicated problems.
Wasn't quite sure how to do that.
I knew McKinsey solved
complicated problems.
Even if they weren't exactly the
problems I wanted to solve long term,
I thought it'd be a good
way to get some skills,
and also just to understand how the
world works, how the economy works.
All these thing that
seemed kind of vague to me,
that I thought I could
kind of get a window into.
Voiceover: So what was
that experience like?
Was it what you expected?
Elizabeth: Yeah.
I learned a lot there.
It was a great education.
In a lot of ways it was
like being in school,
because every few months
you're learning something new,
and you're learning all
these different industries,
and solving all these crazy problems
that are probably way beyond,
anything I should have been thinking
about at that point in my life (laughs).
But it was fascinating.
The people were really smart so
I got to learn a lot from them.
Voiceover: And you were very
young and you were in rooms,
with heads of corporations and executives
and that must've been pretty neat.
Elizabeth: Yeah it was cool and
also kind of scary and weird.
There were times I thought like, "Man
this should be a novel or something."
Voiceover: Oh really?
I haven't heard about those.
Elizabeth: It's just so weird.
Voiceover: That'll be future videos.
We'll change the names.
Elizabeth: No, I mean, it was great.
I learned a ton but I knew
I still wanted to get back,
to the problems that were
really interesting to me.
And McKinsey does work
on that to some extent,
but a lot of what I was doing
were problems that were different,
than the ones I really
wanted to spend my time on.
I thought maybe I'd go
get some more skills,
and go to law school.
As we've talked about, I was planning to
go to law school right after McKinsey,
and work on human rights, go back to what
I really had wanted to do for a while.
Then I heard about Khan Academy
and just sounded really exciting,
and of course, I know I'll embarrass
you, but I watched the Ted Talk,
I was very inspired.
I'm very excited.
I heard that Khan Academy was looking
to put together a schools team,
to work with schools.
It sounded exciting to
me and so here I am.
Voiceover: Was there anything that was ...
because you were on
this kind of fast track.
You were at McKinsey.
You spent what 2, 3 years?
Elizabeth: 3 years, yeah.
Voiceover: 3 years at McKinsey and,
actually, I saw some of your reviews.
You were like one of the most
highly rated person we've ...
[Shadnu] told me that, "The
type of ratings Elizabeth gets,
"not very few people at McKinsey get."
So you were on this fast track, you're
set probably for a very good law school.
Was it just the mission?
That we're education?
What spoke to you about this whole thing?
Elizabeth: Yeah, it was
largely the mission.
I think that mission means a lot to me.
Knowing that I could get up every
morning and work on something,
that I'm really excited
about was a lot of it.
It was also something even
bigger than the mission,
if there's anything bigger than
educating the whole world for free,
I don't know.
I think it was getting
to start something new.
It was this idea that,
how often in your life,
does someone come along and say
to you, "Be part of this team,
"that's building something
that doesn't yet exist."
It's not just sort of different than
a bunch of other things that exist.
It's something totally new that's
trying to solve a really, really tough,
entrenched social problem.
It's a start up and maybe
it'll work and maybe it won't,
but it's going to be with a lot
of really smart, dedicated people,
who really want to make a go of it.
That's exciting.
I think that I just felt like I could
stay on the tried and true path,
and I'm sure that would have
been rewarding in its own right.
Or I could branch off that and try
to build something from scratch,
with a lot of other awesome people.
And try to make a goal of it.
Really try to solve this problem.
I just felt like I couldn't
pass up the opportunity.
Voiceover: You joined,
about 7 or 8 months now,
at the time we're doing this
interview in late February of 2012.
Is there anything that's been surprising,
or it's just as you expected?
Exactly as you visualized it while
you were about to leave McKinsey?
Or disappointing?
What's your view of things so far?
Elizabeth: Yeah, I think I'd have
to have an amazing crystal ball,
or something to know exactly
what it would look like.
I really didn't exactly know what
I was getting myself into at all.
It's been exciting.
Voiceover: That's how I live my life.
Elizabeth: Yeah (laughs).
It's been really fun.
I've been really happy to be here.
I think some of the things
that have been surprising,
have just been the scale of change,
and the pace at which we're working.
I guess, when I joined in July, we'd
worked with one school district,
Los Altos, and we're
still working with them.
But instead of working with
4 teachers they were working,
with a whole bunch of teachers in
the district, about 40 of them.
Then we have all these other
schools we're working with as well.
Voiceover: It's like
10,000 people sounds like.
Elizabeth: 10,000 people yeah.
Voiceover: It's probably
12,000 now [unintelligible].
Elizabeth: Yeah.
It's growing so fast.
And what's amazing is we're working
really closely with these schools,
and that's great for those few schools,
and that's where we're really
seeing a lot of the innovation.
But then, every time we discover something
exciting at a school we're working with,
we can just throw it up online
and then all these other people,
around the world can
see it and use it too.
Or we'll say, "Oh wow. It'd be great
if we had exercises on this topic,
"or features on our site that
would help schools in these ways."
Then we can create them
with the rest of the team,
and then suddenly there's millions
of people around the world,
who are benefiting from those.
It's really fast, rapid
movement from having an idea,
to making the idea happen.
To having it affect a lot of people.
I think that's something that's exciting,
probably about software in general.
But especially here, where
it's like we don't have a way,
for people to graph linear equations.
Let's create a way for them
to graph linear equations.
Oh wow, look.
A million people just
graphed linear equations.
That's exciting to see.
Voiceover: What are your hopes?
Over the next couple of years or whatever.
What are you hoping to see happen?
Elizabeth: Well, I'm hoping that we're
going to reach a lot more people,
around the world.
I'm hoping for a lot of things.
As someone on the schools
team I'm really excited,
about helping to push the
boundaries on education.
I think there's a lot
of people in education,
who've been coming up with
lots of innovative ideas,
and wanting to do a lot
of things for a long time.
Teachers really want to meet
the needs of all their students,
but they haven't had the
tools to be able to do that.
Teachers might have been willing
to question a lot of assumptions,
in education but haven't
really had the right tools,
to make that happen.
I'm excited to work with
those kinds of teachers,
in those schools.
To say, "Let's get rid of age
based grouping. Let's throw out,
"all these basic assumptions we
have about a 9 month school year,
"and about students plodding
along from 45 minutes of this,
"to 45 minutes of that. Why do you
have to have math class separate,
"from science class,
separate from art class?"
I'm excited to work with schools that
want to break those boundaries down,
and see what we can do to
make learning more exciting,
and more engaging for students.
Then take whatever we learn
there and help translate that,
through our platform to
the rest of the world.
So that people who even
aren't in schools like that,
can still have similar
exciting learning experiences.
Voiceover: Very cool.